wealthy friends like some of them don't
drink some of them drink a ton some of
them watch some of them don't watch at
all and also make tons of money success
doesn't really care or the result
doesn't really care 1 plus one if you
still do the addition it equals two
whether you're a good person or you're a
bad person if you make a 100 calls or
you you know make a 100 pieces of
content the likelihood that somebody
will find out your product is greater
than if you make zero period fight me
you can drink and do drugs and watch if
you still do the that's all that
matters now those things might make it
more difficult but I I always came from
the perspective of like I want to do the
formula and then live my life how I want
to live and if that means that sometimes
I drink more and sometimes I drink less
or sometimes I work out more and
sometimes work out less that's fine